Welcome back to human emotion here.
We're going to wonder whether early man actually had emotions or are they a more
recent evolutionary phenomena?
That is are we evolved to be emotional,
our emotions evolutionarily evolved.
In this lecture today we're going to discuss to what extent emotions are
evolutionarily evolved here.
We're going to start with an introduction to some basic principles of evolution
and we'll move on to explain how those principles may be used to better
understand the origins of human emotion.
So here is our roadmap for today.
We're going to start with some origins of evolutionary theory,
talk about the EEA,
which I'll describe later.
Think about what an evolutionary approach is to emotion,
and we'll conclude with our takeaway questions and expert interview.
So let's start here with some of the Orrin origins or where evolutionary theory
came from.
So this might look familiar to you from one of our first lectures where we
talked about this sort of chronological theories of emotion or our theories of
emotion timeline.
Here we're going to take a stop at Darwin as we try to trace the origins of
evolutionary theory here.
You might also remember from our earlier lecture that Darwin was really seen as
the founder of the evolutionary approach to emotions.
Here he saw or said that emotions,
we're evolutionarily evolved and that they were here to serve an important
survival purpose for man.
In other words,
he argued that emotions evolve via natural selection and serve this purpose for
humans.
Critical surface verse survival and helping aid and communication and bonds with
feathers.
Darwin detailed these thoughts in his landmark book,
the expression of the emotions in man and animals here.
This book was immediately a bestseller of its time,
over 5,000 copies,
which was a lot in those days.
And what was fascinating about it is it was really considered the first
scientific treatment of emotion.
It included survey data,
observations of both healthy and mentally ill individuals looking at healthy and
unhealthy emotion,
as well as Darwin's own personal anecdotes,
recounting grief expressions and his family after death,
as well as expressions of early emotion in his own infant son.
So when we think about Darwin and sort of how he approached the evolution of
emotion,
you can think of three principles that he talked about to help explain these
origins of emotion.
His first of the three principles was called the principle of serviceable or
quote,
useful habit.
And this first principle is very important for understanding how emotions
evolved.
He argued that useful habits become reinforced over time.
So for example,
think of the emotion of disgust.
So discuss is really useful in helping to turn us away from ingesting substances
or toxins that might actually make us feel ill.
And here we have discussed because it serves a useful or serviceable habit for
us.
So this is the first principle,
the principle of serviceable or useful habits.
We have emotions because they serve these useful functions for us.
Now we'll look at this second principle,
which he called the principle of antithesis.
So while some emotional habits are useful,
which we just talked about in the case of discussed,
other emotions are what he called emotional habits occur merely because they
are,
they're opposite,
he would say,
or antithesis.
So,
for example,
if you encounter some opposite situation in which you typically elicit a
habitual response,
for example,
maybe rotten food,
an opposite manner of the habit will occur,
such as the opposite of the emotion of disgust.
This principle,
the principle antithesis was the one that received perhaps the least attention
of all three.
The third,
which will turn to is the principle of involuntariness or what he called
nervous,
a discharge.
So some he would say some evolve behaviors or habits are performed as the result
of built up energy in the nervous system.
And this would lead to a nervous discharge as he put it.
So think of an example.
When you're in an extreme situation of threat where you feel fear,
he would say,
well,
you have what's called a nervous,
just discharge of screaming.
Um,
other people.
We'll talk about more modern day situations where maybe you're sitting with a
boss or someone that you're very uncomfortable around and you're nervous just
charged my just be even your leg shaking or your arms trembling.
Um,
so he would say that this is this third principle.
were some evolve behaviors or habits are performed as the result of this built
up energy in our nervous system.
So it was the first and third principle.
So the principle of serviceable habit and involuntariness that received the bulk
of attention.
Yeah.
So let's think about what might be some supportive evidence for Darren's
overarching claim that emotions are evolved and transmitted across time.
Okay.
So some of the evidence that Darren talked about here,
the first example is what he called the inheritance of expressions.
So he argued that emotions are largely inherited in us and learned and that most
of our important expressions are in us from birth.
So he would use the example of newborn babies as you can see here who admit
displays of distress and crying or screaming immediately on birth.
So he would say that we're just born with a lot of these emotional expressions.
And he would also talk about individuals who are born blind and nonetheless
exhibit similar emotion expressions as seeing individuals.
We've thus,
he would say,
inherited many of our most vital emotion expressions here.
He would talk about,
uh,
another instance,
our example,
um,
which he called instinctive recognition of emotion.
So here you might see a dog.
And if I asked you,
well,
what emotion is that dog feeling?
He would,
we should be immediately able to instinctively recognize that this dogs,
you know,
feeling some sort of threat.
Um,
or he would show an example of a cat here.
These are his original drawings in his book,
which is the cat terrified at a dog.
So what Darwin noticed in these drawings is that many emotions,
um,
what he referred to as expressive actions are actually apparent in other species
such as we saw this sort of,
uh,
you know,
angry dog or fearful countenance here of this kitty.
And he would say that we have this ability instinctively to recognize emotions,
not only in humans,
but even in animals.
Even if you've never seen this cat or dog before.
It sort of built in us to know what emotions are and see them in others.
He would also argue that we should be able to see emotions and recognize them
across humans of varying ages and backgrounds as well.
And here's some more of Darwin's original drawings in his book,
um,
where we can see him depicting emotional expressions of fear and a grown man as
well.
As you can see here on the right in this plate.
One is,
he called it,
um,
six different expressions of emotions even in young children and infants.
Um,
and that what we see here is not only similar morphological features across
time,
but that we're all able to pick up on what these young children are expressing,
you know,
distress,
um,
sadness,
perhaps frustration that were built to be able to,
uh,
recognize these expressions.
So in some Darwin would say most of our emotion expressions are an eight.
That emotions remained virtually static or constant throughout our life.
But he did argue that not all emotional expressions are a sort of instinctive,
that there's some things he would say like kissing for example,
that are learn but are used to fulfill a more evolutionarily primal desire.
So most of our expressions,
our instinctive,
but those that are not are things we learned to fulfill more evolutionarily or
instinctive needs.
So now we're gonna move on to our second point in the roadmap where we're going
to talk about the EEA and the EA stands for the environment of evolutionary
adaptiveness.
Okay.
So you might wonder,
well,
what is the EA?
Well,
the EA is the environment which forms a sort of the origin of human kind and
it's where emotions are thought to have first evolved.
So when we think of what is the EA,
what we're trying to get at is what is an accurate picture of the environment in
which human emotions sort of first developed or originated.
So what did this early evolutionary environment look like?
Um,
and so when people try to think about what the EEA is,
what they often do is sort of try to look into other preindustrial societies,
hunter gatherer societies,
as you can see here,
um,
to try to think about what might be close analogies or parallels.
And so one particular group that's been studied,
um,
is a new Guinea.
Um,
and for example,
here you look at people living in environments that may be similar to those that
we lived in an earlier times and that might help explain some of our early
emotional heritage.
So when we think more specifically,
what are the EEA properties?
So what did this early environment of man look like that may have given rise to
and help explain some of our modern day,
uh,
emotional tendencies.
So interestingly,
the first sort of property of sort of early kind of human environments,
uh,
were what he called the vulnerability of offspring.
So in other words,
we know that as human beings,
our frontal cortex expands dramatically and over time the birth canal has
narrowed.
So that what we have now is children who are born.
What is thought of as prematurely in so far as after infants are born,
there are highly dependent on their caregiver for a long period of time before
they can function independently.
So,
because as humans,
we're very dependent on our caregiver for many years.
It's really important that,
you know,
we have emotions that are built into us that help us want to care for our young
and offspring.
So,
um,
in other words,
emotions like compassion or prosocial feelings of nurturant love became really
important in our early history as a vital part of promoting this longterm care
of offspring in hunter gatherer societies.
Um,
so what it seems to be the cases that ea would be the kind of environment where
compassion and love would be really important emotions.
The second property is what has been thought of as monogamous bonds.
So human society seems to have by and large a strong underlying tone of monogamy
or some sort of longterm commitment to a partner to help rear these vulnerable
offspring.
Uh,
this is in contrast to Banabos,
uh,
for example,
who are monkeys who like to have sex often and with many other monkeys.
And they often do this to resolve conflict.
Um,
so I often joke with my students that it seems like everyone would love to be a
Bonobo.
They're often thought of as a hippie of monkeys,
but for humans that seems that's often less the case.
Maybe for the most part that at least for rearing offspring,
these monogamous bonds are really important.
And so we want to have emotions built in us that enabled us to be connected in a
longterm way to a partner to help care and sort of rear these offspring.
Okay.
The third property is what's thought of as the emergence of caring and
compassion.
So here,
uh,
jet diamond and others have written about the emergence of caring among humans.
So part of this is due to the fact that hominids,
uh,
began to live longer.
So there were older people who also required caring.
And this has been found among early cro-magnon records.
So it's both the existence of vulnerable offspring,
infants and young children as well as older people,
um,
who have led to societies where it's really important to take care of others who
are vulnerable.
And so these emotions,
again,
of caring for others and having compassion is a vital part of our early origins.
The fourth property is what's often referred to as the flattening of social
hierarchies.
So here,
it's really interesting because research is actually suggested that the social
hierarchy in hunter gatherer societies are actually fairly egalitarian.
So we see hominids you had groups of 75 to a hundred individuals within a given
group.
And we're very,
uh,
sort of egalitarian in the sense.
So,
uh,
again,
Jed diamond here has argued that it's not until more recently within the sort of
advent of agriculture,
um,
this sort of excess production of food we see in modern day society that has led
us away from what he would say are more egalitarian roots and in these
egalitarian roots,
as we'll talk about in our sort of last property here,
it's really important that we sort of act collectively or work together.
There's this,
what it says here need for collective action.
So as a result of living in these large and egalitarianism groups,
uh,
central and important part of society includes a need to cooperate with others.
Paul Ekman,
who we spoke about earlier,
noted that in his journeys to the preindustrial society of New Guinea,
um,
in this cultural tribe,
you constantly see individuals engage in collective behavior and sharing tasks.
So it seems to be an important part of our evolutionary roots.
So as you can see,
the EA has many properties that seem to give rise to social emotions ranging
from compassion and love to cooperative behaviors and feelings.
So at our core it seems that we're a highly social and cooperative society and
have many emotions that help foster these kinds of feelings.
Um,
and in some the EEA also resulted in certain selection pressures that favorite
certain genes more than others,
and that these genes drive which emotions become adaptive and universal across
all human beings.
So now we're going to turn to an evolutionary approach.
And here you might wonder,
well,
what is an evolutionary approach in the first place to understanding human
emotion?
What are the key concepts to grasp as we start to apply these theories of man
and how he evolved over time to our present day emotions,
these things that seems so intimate and so familiar to us.
What do we need to know?
So
here,
one of,
um,
the kind of five big ideas behind an evolutionary approach to grasp is the first
here you can see at the top gene replication.
So we're designed to replicate not ourselves as individuals,
but our genes and our genes form us as biochemical and physiological processes
underlying the basis of our behavior.
And evolution operates on jeans with the focus of seeing genes make it to the
next generation over time.
Okay.
Second is this idea of selection pressures.
So this is something that Darwin first articulated.
He said that natural selection focuses us,
um,
in a way on how certain environmental factors or events may either increase or
decrease the likelihood of gene replication.
Right?
And so this is the idea of the selection pressures that either pushed towards or
pull away the likelihood of certain genes getting propagated over time.
And um,
what's interesting when you think about selection pressures as he talked about
sort of three categories to understand.
As you can see here at the bottom,
natural selection pressures,
sexual selection pressures and group selection pressures.
So natural selection pressures are forces that increase or decrease the
likelihood you're going to survive to an age where you could reproduce.
So these include things like how well do you avoid predators and disease?
How well are you able to acquire adequate nutrition,
sexual selection pressures?
I'm referred to this idea that our genes only make it to the next generation if
they convinced the individual to reproduce.
So these include both intrasexual,
an intersexual selection,
pressures in trust,
sexual pressures are those that are within the same sex.
So for example,
males may compete with each other to gain status,
which in turn makes it easier to find females to reproduce with.
In terms sexual pressures are first example,
the way in which,
um,
choices exercise in finding mates.
So between female and male mates.
So for example,
males with more material resources,
um,
are often preferred by females.
So evolutionary theory with state.
And then finally at the bottom are these groups selection pressures.
So this category is more controversial.
So here,
researchers have found that mammals who are more effective group members,
so they're more cooperative,
they're more likable,
are actually more able to produce.
So this is controversial because it says that nicer people who are more
cooperative are more likely to have their jeans transmitted through time.
So,
um,
researchers you can see here,
Lita cosmetics and John Tooby,
a from UC Santa Barbara really sort of,
um,
are the pioneers that you can think of and this evolutionary approach to motion.
So they focus on our a environment in order to better understand our emotional
origins.
Um,
and as described earlier,
the EA is a Savannah hunter gatherer society with a strong social hierarchy.
So here you,
these two researchers who will speak with in our expert interview,
uh,
focused on an environment in which people evolved to understand emotional
origins.
And they would say here,
emotion is the statistical composite of selection pressures that cause the genes
underlying the design of an adaptation to increase in frequency until they
became species typical or stable.
Persistent.
So another words,
they really thought of emotions as these hardwired what they called programs or
modules.
So here the mind is supposed to be composed of a variety of these mini modules
or programs which help us solve these recurring evolutionary issues.
And these programs that are built into our mind get either turned on or
triggered,
uh,
or turned off by certain solicitors in our environment.
So they often use the example of the snake,
as you can see here.
So the snake is really this kind of illicit or in the environment that sort of
switches on or turns on our fear program in our brain.
And from that comes a cascade of an experience of fear,
that behavior to sort of flee,
um,
and heightened physiological arousal.
So it's that we have this module in our mind and the snake just flips that
module on.
And that's our module of fear.
Yeah.
So we're going to conclude today with our takeaway questions.
And here,
think about what are the key concepts to grasp when we think about an
evolutionary approach and begin to start to think about how it applies to
emotion.
So our takeaway questions are three as usual,
and they go as follows.
So the first ass,
what are Darwin's three principals on the origin of emotions?
Okay,
what are the main properties of the EEA and how do they give rise to certain
human emotions?
Finally,
how would you summarize to be in cause NEIdeas evolutionary approach to emotion?
And we conclude with a very exciting expert interview as part of our experts in
emotion interview series.
Okay.
Today,
uh,
for our experts in emotion interview,
we have the honor of speaking with doctors,
Lita cosmetics and John tooby together who will help us answer the question of
whether and how emotions are products of our evolutionary history or our
emotions evolutionarily evolved.
So doctor [inaudible] and two B are well known for their work in pioneering the
field of evolutionary psychology.
They're both professors of psychology and anthropology at Uc Santa Barbara where
they code direct the center for evolutionary psychology.
They began their collaboration 29 years ago at Harvard University as
undergraduates,
and have received since then,
numerous awards,
including the NIH director's pioneer award,
the American Association for the Advancement of Science Prize for Behavioral
Research,
American psychological associations,
early career award,
um,
the national science science foundations,
presidential young investigator award,
and Guggenheim.
So I now turn to a very special one of a kind duo experts and emotion interview
together with Dr Lita Cosmetics and Dr John tooby.
Okay.
And so thank you for another great class.